i wrote this as a poem for my husband
and our son archie and then turned it
into a book so you could enjoy it too
meghan markle is creating art all in the
name of family today i'm going to read
to you my book called the bench yes the
bench is the children's book written by
the duchess of sussex inspired by her
husband prince harry and their son
two-year-old archie in a new video
posted to brightly story times youtube
page megan read the short story which
she sweetly dedicated to her favorite
guys for the man and the boy
who make my heart go pump punk and get
this rumor has it the book earned megan
a pretty sweet payday well there are
lots of rumors flying around about how
much megan received um seven hundred
thousand dollars is one of the figures i
think that sounds pretty high but it's
fair to say that she is going to have
received a sizable advance and that is
largely because of the name on the front
page
megan duchess of sussex the book which
features illustrations by christian
robinson shows the bond between a father
and son sharing meaningful conversations
about life on a special bench the red
hair signature beard and the cute baby
safe to say robinson totally captured
the essence of the prince and his son
this is your bench
where life will begin
for you and our son
our baby
our kin but this isn't a book about the
sussexes you'll notice there's a variety
of fathers and sons included in the
story sharing heartfelt moments together
some days he may cry
perched there on your knee
he'll feel happiness
sorrow
one day be heartbroken
you'll tell him i love you
those words always spoken
megan concludes her reading and leaves
us with this final message
i hope you enjoyed the bench i loved
being able to share it with you and now
i hope you're able to go and find your
own special bench or a chair or a little
quiet nook just a place that means
something to you that you can share with
someone you love i think this will
probably be uh the first of
several books to come in the future but
this isn't the only reading of the bench
the duchess has done recently last month
during a visit to new york city megan
shared her story with a group of lucky
second grade students and look closely
that's prince harry sitting cross-legged
with the kids on the ground listening on
you'll
according to abc 7 new york megan shared
a sentimental story with the children
about the meaning behind the book
explaining quote i was at the moment
witnessing my husband with our son when
he'd just been born and watching that
this could be a place where they could
continue to grow and connect and learn
and that could be anywhere so it's about
finding that special place for you
that's in your heart and wherever you
find it to always go and reset and go ah
this feels good come back to brightly
story time soon bye